hello miss coffee bean and her team of
archaeologists
discovered an ancient machine learning
paper
and the finding is interesting for three
reasons
firstly the paper solves a part of
symbolic mathematics with deep neural
networks surpassing
even the mighty mathematica on the test
set
secondly it is not really
self-supervised learning but
yet the amount of training data for this
task is virtually
infinite stick around to see why and
thirdly it is one of miss coffee beans
favorite papers
i think she has a weak spot for
mathematics so welcome to this ai coffee
break
where you will find out how artificial
intelligence tackles symbolic
mathematics
deep learning can do symbolic
mathematics or at least a part of it
as far as this paper goes but why should
anybody care about this
well you should be hyped because of at
least two reasons
first mathematics follows rigorous rules
and
is exact perhaps you remember that
e to the power of x integrated is again
e to the power of
x plus a constant and nothing else would
be the answer here
but deep learning with its neural
networks is clearly statistical
which can be seen as an opposite to
rule-based systems where
you could prove that you arrive at the
right answer 100 percent of the time one
more reason to care about neural
networks
solving symbolic mathematics is exactly
the
symbolic nature of this problem neural
networks had huge success on domains
where representations are continuous in
the first place
like in computer vision where pixels
take continuous values
dark spots take low values while bright
pixels have
large values but while neural networks
perform well
on continuous problems they are still
struggling with
symbolic reasoning so with exactly the
mathematical equation
this paper deals with which are in forms
like
x plus y which could stand for any two
numbers being added up
while the numerical expression is
continuous
as there are several other numbers
between two
and three x and y are the opposite of
continuous they
are symbols that can stand for numbers
or
even for other symbols and there's
nothing in between the symbol
x and the symbol y so to say the only
relationship defined here is stated
in the equation but that's about it and
the neural network so far
have been applied on numeric tasks where
the network gets as inputs two numbers
and the output is again a number
like adding or multiplying two numbers
and there
they perform quite poorly but this paper
considers
the symbolic type of calculations where
the input is an equation describing the
relationship of symbols and the output
is again
in symbolic form but this time
representing the solution
if you remember from mathematics classes
depicted here
is integration another set of symbolic
mathematics
problems are first and second order
ordinary differential
equations or short odes miss coffee bean
thinks that it is here
in the problem choice where the genius
of the paper
is condensed for this video we will
stick with the integration
since we want to stay at the beginner
level and odes are renowned to scare
people
for everyone interested in odes check
out the paper linked in the video
description
disclaimer it works very similar to
integration
so we think we agreed that both
integration
and odes are hard for humans and now we
want to
solve symbolic integration with neural
networks but
neural networks require training data so
pairs of functions and their integrals
where to get that from
we could generate some functions
randomly and take
systems like matlab and mathematica to
predict the integral
but these systems are not very fast and
sometimes
fail even for integrable functions so
forward generation
is a good start for some training data
but won't get us far and we won't be
better than mathematica
therefore a little out of the box
thinking is required integration is hard
but the backward operation to it is
differentiation which is fast
easy to compute following simple rules
so let's use this lesson and
additionally to forward generation
use something else by generating random
functions on the
output side instead of the input side
and then
computing their derivatives these
function pairs can be then added to the
training pool
this is cool and it's called backward
generation and it can generate
a lot of hard examples but has the
following problem
it is very unlikely to randomly generate
very complicated examples in the first
place and even more unlikely
is to have them simplify to a very
simple function
in the derivative it is important to
have these long short combinations too
otherwise the network could become
biased to long
equations to address this the authors
use another clever trick
two random functions f and g are
generated
their derivatives small f and small g
are computed
and these pairs are added to the
training set but now
with the rule of integration by parts
one can also add the training set
combinations of these f and g
functions like this f times g is already
known because it is already in the
training set
only that the second term is unknown
we know small f and the integral of g
but we do not know the integral of f
times g
but with enough luck it might already be
in the training set
if this already contains a lot of stuff
generated with forward and backward
generation beforehand
so every time the authors discover
something like this
in the training set they generate a new
data point by backward generation with
integration by parts but miss coffee
bean wait a little
the authors have now three means of
generating as much training data as they
want with
forward and backward generation also
using integration by parts but
all this relies on randomly generating
functions which
are then either integrated or
differentiated
so three questions remain how to
generate functions randomly
and how to feed them into a neural
network
and what is this mysterious neural
network anyway
okay we will answer these questions one
at a time to randomly generate functions
we first need a way to represent
mathematical expressions
the choice here falls to trees where
operators and functions are
internal nodes the operands are children
and
constants and variables are leaps the
choice falls to trees because of lots of
reasons
trees represent the order in which
operations are executed
associativity is clear and parentheses
become obsolete
and because of this they are very easy
to grow on the other hand
expanding expressions in the sequential
representation
is very clear at both ends but adding
something in between
might get a little messy so yeah if one
wants to grow an expression randomly one
just has to randomly select functions
operators and operands randomly and just
check
that unary operands like sinuses or
exponentials
get only one child while binary operands
like addition or multiplication
get two children then on to the second
question
how to process mathematical expressions
now in form of
trees by a neural network well we don't
process the trees
wait what the authors linearize the
trees to a sequence again
by using prefix notation where each node
is written before
its children from left to right like in
this example
the advantage over the common way of
writing mathematical expressions
is that the prefix notation does not
require any parenthesis
which would make the life of the neural
network harder by having to remember to
close them after they have been opened
so
no trees neural networks working on
trees were very
unvogue in natural language processing
c3 lstms but now
nlp is dominated by transformers and
guess what
the neural network employs to solve
symbolic integration
and odes is a transformer you did not
expect that to happen
right transformers are now everywhere
yeah
so the authors use a transformer
architecture to translate from the input
sequence to the output sequence and
with the awesome data generation
procedure that can generate virtually
infinite amounts of it there is enough
data for the transformer to learn the
problem
it does not really matter that symbolic
integration is hard
i think we all agree here because there
is enough data which
proves to be in this case 20 million
examples yeah they generated 20 million
data samples just
like that this is why miss coffee bean
thinks that this is genius take this
equation
you want to maximize research results
you know
transformers can do anything so of
course you use them
you have your problem but you realize
it's limited
data is too little for the transformer
to learn something meaningful
but you still want to do good research
so you choose an application where you
have virtually
infinite amounts of data and the recipe
to maximizing success
is set well don't take miss coffee bean
so seriously but
it seems like this is kind of the recipe
for success nowadays
and this is what partially happens in
self-supervised learning because
there you have almost infinite amounts
of
training data so yeah in any case
the 20 million samples that the authors
here have
seem to be very effective because their
transformer network is able to solve the
integration examples with around
99 accuracy in less than a second
for example while mathematica given 30
seconds of compute time can only solve
84 percent maple 67
and matlab only 65
but what are the remaining one percent
in integration performance
of the transformer well we
remember that we are in the statistical
world of
neural networks so until we meet you
next time
watch out for outliers if you wander out
alone in this
world and hey do not forget to like and
subscribe
you